our community has lost long-time las
vegas resident steven shore
he was a former news reporter anchor
right here at klas-tv
and had many accomplishments to his name
he was most
recognized as the long-time spokesman
for cox communications
where he previously served as vp of
public and government affairs
kirsten joyce joins us now with a bit
more brian
received a statement from the shore
family saying in part that he passed
away yesterday at the age of 74 from
natural causes
the family says over the past 40 years
steve was widely recognized for his
tireless and lengthy community
involvement
with civic organizations youth groups
and at one point
had served on the board of directors of
20 local non-profits
we've got a picture of steve when he
worked here at klas in the 1980s as an
investigative reporter and then went on
to anchor receiving many awards for
journalism
also he was a familiar face as the mc of
best in show for many many years
president peter guzman of the latin
chamber of commerce says steve had a
35-year history as a volunteer
with the chamber i always loved picking
his brain and hearing about
old vegas because i love old vegas and
he just had a way of doing it with
dignity and kindness and
even when he scolded you and he had he
scolded me a couple times on
you know his thoughts on certain things
that i was doing at the chamber and
how i could be doing it better he always
did it with dignity and kindness
when you lose good people like this
giants in our community
guys who really uh steve had a way of
connecting with grassroots and
and ceos i mean you know he treated
everybody the same and
i always appreciated that about him and
it just hits home when you lose a kind
man like that uh
one of our own and his family said he
was most proud of his
wife his sons and grandchildren and all
the students at his namesake steve shore
elementary school
donations and funeral services are still
pending
brian and cure we heard from a number of
people today including friend and
former anchor gary waddell gary said i
worked with steve a number of times when
he was at channel 8 and when he was
doing things
in our community the magnitude of his
community involvement in las vegas
is truly amazing he was always kind and
always a gentleman
he will truly be missed by all in
southern nevada and leaves a vacancy in
this
community that will be impossible for
one person to fill
rest in peace my friend rest in peace